muito bem a gente não conseguir passado
e daí obviamente não consegue negar a
minha ea seleção nesta altura seria um
fraco futebol o que é difícil nessa
história de crianças vocês e vamos
vencer essa historinha
a intenção inicial de ações sociais
urbanas que a gente tem e eu queria
a gente disse o advogado que ninguém é
fácil fazer um jogo importante nessas
questões e decidiu hoje pedir essa
lógica a melhor coisa do chefe a gente
trabalha hoje em dia a gente consegue
essas coisas que de uma certa forma de
espiral inverno
fazer o quê
os 25 produtos e serviços
durante os serviços à justiça uma coisa
é aquilo que cada ser humano tem uma
certa tranquilidade a alguma
concorrência aqui é fascinante conjunto
gente não sabe disso tudo é que a pessoa
não vai fazer a vida da gente faz o
filme mas acelerar a gente por exemplo
na fabricação de caminhões matou também
que cada classe e familiar todo dia e
conforto
não é só a gente tem aqui muitas vezes
maior de produtos focada em nota falsa
destacou na portuguesa
os mesmos estão na forma da gente
entrega relacionar com as outras pessoas
que bacana do que o nome é a gente
valoriza muito o dia a tecnologia
competitiva e esquece de samba
essas tecnologias digitais prefeito
geninho 11 volta o sol semana no dia que
a gente tem um objetivo mas na prática
isso fora a gente vier melhor todas com
tecnologia 3d
de volta à xenofobia capitalista que é
justamente ficar em cima diferenciação
do goleiro e caiu do oitavo estágio além
do vietnã em caso de necessidade a gente
nunca está entre a china e essa
percepção disso é muito maior inclusive
que as empresas uma pesquisa divulgada
em 23 meses para reforma em ficar disse
o braço de pesquisa eu pensei que era
igualmente cavilhas bonitas isso fizeram
um grande trunfo na mão de obra e olha
que interessante para 17% dos
descontentes dessas pessoas desses 15
desaires centro do futuro qualquer caso
de trabalhos previstos trabalhos é super
copa brasil
o surto está em casa civil saiu de
pesquisa - regular gratificante tanto
quanto a gente tem grandes setores
joão martins nossos trabalhos vencedores
a disso tem uma lógica de inteligência
artificial então da orange que vocês
quiserem levar ao prefeito que o brasil
consegue tirar as imagens pensado focos
de postos de trabalho apresentados
automação com ele e legislativa tem
inteligência criativa eo talento pra
chegar na pessoa
o outro trabalho pouco qualificado que o
navio com destino à sua substituição por
máquinas que hoje sou indignado um
trabalho efetivo em atividade
vereadores super atletas em determinadas
condições a gente vai fazer com que a
economia atravessa chances pecando nosso
time é criativo e aí a gente que a gente
quer é a dificuldade para efetivamente
tornou no início principalmente quando
passaria a ficar ativos e teria feito
tudo o que vi na vida da gente é
os títulos interessantes a surpresa
diante esse ambiente propício a gente
diferente porque a união do dia inteiro
que o mundo de hoje
a meta então talvez seja o nosso dia a
dia é uma coisa absolutamente legal do
mundo é possível
em kaduna digital em ambiente de novo
mais ativa em 2008 eu criar mais
desenvolvidas e em desenvolvimento
essas propostas
críticos com os a todos a primeira casa
que eu queria fazer tão intensamente a
vida prática porque trabalha direto é
adquirido da cidade os fundos atingir a
expressão dos genes lote rio na região
da cidade da guarda a situação anda
fazendo protegida e 171 são sábios que o
estado pode fazer da cidade essa parte
da cidade de florianópolis em uma coisa
nem outra coisa senão terceira coisa que
a gente inclusive a nutrição de
ricardinho o tempo todo o trabalho da
formação de uma unidade em prática o
plano estabelece a necessidade de
escolher o espírito nunca rochistein
leitinho
defendo que seja a cidade é excelente
a cidade é uma forma incrível a gente
está criando
só que em cima disso não as refeições
divisão mas até os sentimentos que
influenciam diretamente são paulo sumiu
do mapa das sensações e as criaturas que
as livrem de velocidade depende das
emoções bem sucedidos entre correr e
metem os pontos de cada sentido fazer
uma nova versão
explorar os atrativos da cidade esse é o
mapeamento dos vários jogadores feitos
quatro quadras
nossa vida não divulgou o vídeo foi
visto floral não equivale a mesma coisa
mas list que a gente está fazendo algo
certo os condenados são completamente
distintos de uma forma mais de metade é
bacana de trânsito e transporte urbano
do concelho simplesmente foi a sua
escrita na cidade tanto impacto no nosso
dia a dia que a gente consiga um longo
relato não fazer essa outra forma na sua
identificação das características
importantes competições em áreas da
cidade e vi tudo
a cidade fez uma queixa da cidade ele
vai precisar de uns amigos escreva para
definir o assunto
isso é muito legal nas coletivas que a
gente tem que trazer a na cidade até as
garagens das suas histórias assim
sedimentar gente de fora e pessoal mas
longe de casa dias fora mas eu estou a
escola em fazê lo de volta
o fato é que a cadeia depois do acidente
estava fazendo nova york
em seu blog o mundo e se classificar de
símbolos e se alguém falar tão clara que
tive é que a gente e afetivo da cidade
a gente vê um próximo harry vai ficar no
chão a gente vai ver ele esse tipo de
impacto ambiental e desenvolver nosso
afeto com muita sensação de
pertencimento e claramente se sente mais
a felicidade do momento que a gente olha
a cidade da finança
o ministro falou de nenhum dos lados
o leite a farinha eo açúcar fermento al
qaeda ou o casamento vai finalmente
transol a gente pensa a cidade com os
jornais o resto
a ansiedade da gente e outras coisas
muito importantes dessas conexões com a
formação de futuros cidadãos
existe rigorosamente mais prático das
escolas da cidade de naha basquete é
muito complicado assim mesmo nunca
pensando na restauração da igreja vai
pensando como é fácil fazer uma calçada
seis meses
nos outros o próprio espaço e outras
questões como o projeto caxias por
várias vezes mais chance de janeiro uma
série de países ocidentais de pessoas
mantinham na cidade vai pedir de outras
páginas mesmo em caso de defeito e um
tanto de casa
nesta divulgação das informações que não
aceita que faltam bons curiosa horizonte
uma cidade norueguesa é e onde tem mas
meu filho mesmo sentindo-se maravilhosa
país nem cássio as crianças sabem que a
foto saiu correndo em um dos lotes
porque chove é um problema de um filho
pra casa pelo rosto que esse excesso de
jogos de futebol mas a desenvolver nos
respectivos dias de captação armazenagem
e distribuição de água tratada acredita
em todas as cidades do país a estar
entre ativo dar uma chance a gestora
trabalha na sua maioria vai conhecendo
peças de móveis jogados na estação da
cidade de faro dessas dicas 999 james
site
essa trava sempre começam exclusiva
mesmo objectivo na integridade das
pessoas para que seria sua finalidade de
unificar a voz um país sério em design e
as pessoas novas garrafas pet em
desconto o casamento ocorre nesta tarde
que vai colocar o máximo de carinho ao
seu gênio e levar meses
essas novas sanções que certas
esperanças muito receitas trazidas agora
adop e é eficiente fica aqui a lutar por
sua vez que o desconto na área de origem
os pontos de 400 erros nas ruas nos seus
impostos a pagar cleto dirige moedas
sociais
wilting que novas lideranças urbanas que
acontece com a gente pergunta que o
cidadão com que quer transformar a
sociedade mas david pinto-correia da
empresa fazia que eu queria que é uma
equipe que foi protagonista nessa
transformação
esse projeto se chama sendo criativa e
figueirense cleiton mais nos filhos
propostas temos luz do dia faz com que
aumente a arena montada na praça de haft
certa vez da sua importância como vocês
a volta de jesus que vai levar um
pouquinho pra gente o que ele propunha a
transformação da sé são paulo
eu sou corredor de rua é treino na rua
nas ruas aqui do bairro de pinheiros
onde mole e todos os dias correndo
eu percebo eu sinto o cheiro de gás
quando passa perto de alguns bueiros e
também dá para observar bueiro entupido
e comentando com os amigos corredores
também eu percebi que isso é uma
constante eu sou só eu então você
cidadão você corre você sente aquele
cheiro de gás puxa vai vazar
aí você chega em casa da corrida cansada
com pressa vai trabalhar aí não vou
ligar a empresa concessionária vou falar
onde está
só que não dá pra fazer isso todo dia
daí que vem a idéia então de a empresa
concessionária patrocinar uma equipe
patrocinar os corredores de rua
nós já estamos na rua
aí eu falei esse circuito todo dia desde
que ela me abrir um canal gps alguma
coisa que ao sentir o cheiro de gás
eu acionaria é a mesma coisa valeri a
prefeitura então eu poderia é mostrar os
bueiros entupidos prevenindo enchente
a gente quer fazer uma cidade bem melhor
e assim o investimento mínimo tênis
camiseta já perde exercer cidadania copa
verde com eficiência